good luck everybody and happy halloween
and first i would like to thank katie
and simone for organizing this really
great event i really enjoy this and
enjoy my stay here
so um what i'm going to talk about is a
is a more like a control problem uh is a
density control of a swarm system and i
was actually going through the
the work i have done to see which one is
more related to pde i think this one
could be the most relevant one
and uh
this talk is going to be light in the
sense there will be no theorems or
proofs
so i think this is suitable for friday
so
what we are interested in is the swan
formation control so what uh
um so what is this one and this target
is clearly closely related to the talk
this morning by olga and also distorted
by three just a while ago so what we are
interested in is really this one so it's
one just a collection of individuals and
specifically here we have a robot and
what we want to do is we want to find a
common strategy so if each of the robots
apply the same strategy they are going
to do what we want them to do so this is
a goal for instance this is a
this is the zhong uh let's show
intel so
and you can see they can form specific
formation you want them to do
okay
so
uh
recently a very popular approach of
doing this is really to view
these swarms as a distribution the
reason we can do this is because in this
formation control is really it doesn't
matter for instance if i want to control
this like maybe a few hundred robot from
this configuration to this configuration
is that indistinguishable to each other
it doesn't matter whether this robot
goes where or this goes where
as long as
uh the fennel configuration looks like
this then it's fine so that is a
major difference between
this type of control problem with the
classic control problem where you really
want to
control the performance of each
individuals so they are
indistinguishable to each other and due
to this reason
basically it's very natural to model the
configuration of the robot as a
distribution so
for instance we can model this as this
distribution and this is this
distribution
and then the goal would be to find a
specific map to go from this
configuration to this configuration you
can either use optimal transport map or
you can use gradient flow so eventually
you would converge there
so
one major problem in most existing work
is that
the collision avoidance interaction is
ignored
so
uh for most
uh realistic swan control systems uh
even so you can apply whatever fancy
policy you have but at the real lowest
level every robot has to uh in in you
have to enforce a a
collision avoidance mechanism there
otherwise they would hit each other and
this is very important in practice
so but in most existing work this is
largely ignored so what the i'm going to
present is one potential approach to
really take this into account when you
design your control policy okay
so more specifically um this is the uh
system so let's say we have n
agent they share basically the same
dynamics
so they interact with each other with
this uh interaction kernel here and the
u is really the control for this agent
and then you have the noise there and if
everything is zero this corresponds to
different dynamics which is fine so our
goal
is to find a strategy
which is the same for everybody
but could be time varying okay so our
goal is to find this strategy so if
everybody here use this strategy then
they would go from this initial
configuration which
is approximately some distribution to
this target configuration
and we also want to import some
optimality so a natural condition is to
say okay i want to minimize the total
effect so that is
that is the problem formulation
okay
and feel free to stop me if you have any
questions this is more like engineering
thought
uh a lot of questions though exciting
depends only uh
the side yes it's only one argument not
a density or it's a yeah or empirical
thanks chief
it's important to emphasize this is a
fully decentralized your policy you
don't need to
really after the policy is fixed you
don't need to talk to your neighbors to
do anything
the interaction is incred included
already in the designing process of this
so sorry here it's not really analyzing
questions
uh no no
yeah no it's that we don't analyze this
we assume this is already enough to
ensure this
yes
yes exactly
thanks
okay so we are interested in this type
of problem in the mean field limit so we
are very interested in this problem is
large so when is large we can
approximate this dynamics using the
machine velocity equation so it looks
like this and the law really captures
the
distribution of the agent and
this is just a standard machine loss of
equation and also put the control here
because this will control the overall
drift
and uh in the midfield limit also the
average control cost we have looks like
this like so because it's your empirical
average i just integral this over low t
so therefore this is our formula so we
have this uh
evolution of the density
and we have the marginal constraint
that's our goal oh yes here i always use
one but it can be any terminal time just
for simplicity so our goal is to solve
this with the optimal basically what we
need is to optimize this whole thing
over low which is the density evolution
and the policy
okay
so this is the midfield limit
and
there are several special cases and
which is already i think most of the
audience here should be very familiar
with after this week's
seminar
so the first one is if we make this
problem
if we just remove the interaction
okay then we get this and this is
exactly the schrodinger bridge problem
and we if we even remove the
the noise the diffusion then this is the
phenomenal linear formulation of the
optimal transport
okay just a two special cases
and just like this uh problems
there's a there's a way
to reformulate
this memphia control problem
uh the density control problem
in terms of optimization problem over
the path measures
and this is what happens
so we assume
p
is the measure
induced by
induced by the control process so this
is the controller dynamics
and
p is the process induced by this
and the load t is the margin of this at
this time t
and this is the
i don't remember what's the map this
type of equation it's a mean fear the
stochastic differential equation could
be
so this one is the one with the control
and the q is the one without control
okay but i want to emphasize that
even though this doesn't have control i
use p here to denote that to emphasize
that
this law is actually the marginal of the
first process so low t is always the
margin of the controlled one
okay so this uncontrollable process so i
mean the one i defined really depends on
the tensile policy
so if we invoke the design of theorem
which is the standard in this domain
this quadratic energy
can be written as the clear divergence
relative entropy between
the controlled process and uncontrolled
uncontrolled process
okay if we combine all of this together
this is what we get
what we need to find is a measure over
the path space which is really high
dimensional infinite dimensional
such that the initial distribution or
the marginal distribution at the zero
time is the initial distribution and the
marginal distribution of the target at
the terminal time is the target
distribution this is our goal and we
want this this to be minimized
okay this is the control energy
this is very similar to the standard
shooting a bridge problem
except for that
yes so ensuring a bridge problem we will
say this is the q is the prior process p
is the process you want and you want to
find the process which is closest to the
player and the and also consistent with
the marginals but here the difference is
that
the prior process
depends on your solution
so that is a major difference and this
is actually makes the
this makes the problem much more
complicated
okay good
i
[Music]
depends on the solution i think somehow
it depends on the control i i got a
little mixture it's here
you see
so the prior process is an artificial
prior process we just made this up
it just fit with this formulation so we
defined this to be the prior process
and the reason this depends on the
control is because here we use this
marginal law
which is the margin of the
control process
external potential for the other process
or a time varying external potential for
the other class yes yes
oh yeah
yes the second one depends on the first
one only on the statistics of the first
one
not only on the other notes of the first
one
okay so you mentioned two particular
cases
in the last line yes they admit the same
reformulation like that
yes the special case
you see for instance showing a bridge
in that case w is 0 w 0 then this is
remove you remove this
so therefore the q doesn't depends on p
so you only have q
so yeah okay yeah it can always be
written in this way if you have noise
okay so if you remove this p over here
this is the standard standard shooting a
bridge problem
okay and move
so even though we were motivated by a
very engineering application this turns
out to
coincide with a really beautiful paper
by berkoff and the giovanni and several
others
it's called the mean fear showing a
bridge problem it's a very beautiful
piece of work
and the units are
quite standard assumptions okay so the
goal here is really just like showing
the bridge the
the story of the schrodinger bridge so
you assume you have n particles
okay
they interact with each other and each
of them have this has this dynamics
okay then they have some initial
distribution
and then you observe this they have this
target empirical distribution at the end
now
the shooting a bridge problem basically
asks for the most likely evolution
between these two observed marginals
considering this is the prior process
okay
it turns out for this problem you can
develop a large deviation principle
which is highly non-trivial but informal
result looks like this
so the probability to observe a specific
evolution p
is proportional to exponential
to the power minus n and the number of
particles multiply these k divergence so
that's why if you want to find the most
likely evolution you really want to
minimize this this guy here
and that is the whole uh actually larger
large deviation story behind the
schrodinger bridge problem but it just
turns out that the thing physics
interpretation carries on for the mean
field
setting
okay
yes so just uh
several more equations no proof
several more equations about this uh
just two so if you are familiar with
this uh control theory then just from
the
from the uh fluid dynamic or the mean
field formulation we have it's not very
difficult to to lay down the uh optimic
condition it's just that the first one
is the edge hamilton jacobi equation
which characterize the optimality and
the option control is the gradient of
some potential function and you just
plug this back so you have a coupled pde
system okay so that is a relatively
standard uh
at least formally
okay but a very surprising result in
this mean field showing a bridge problem
is that
you can just like the standard shooting
a bridge problem
there is a factorization of optimal
density flow
which
looks like this
and then you have these two factors
uh phi and the plus psi and the this
plus i
satisfy the backward equation and the
phi will satisfy this forward equation
and they're coupled with each other in
the specific way and again if you make
the interaction to zero this just
reduced to the standard one
and the two completely cover the system
okay
so just uh some theory i'm not going to
mention this more it's quite complicated
if you're interested in this
this paper is really nice
what what i'm going to talk about is a
algorithm it's a one algorithm to solve
this type of problem so that's what i'm
going to do and uh this class asia
okay so we are going to question
here
and the optimal
good question so the optimal control is
actually grading the flank
yes
yes exactly
if there is no noise
if the option is this uh if there's no
noise you don't have this system
but do you know what do you get
yeah you just make this zero it's fine
the the algorithm the theory goes
through
uh what what do you mean what do you got
so well i presume that the exponential
formula for all people would be
different yeah this this doesn't work
i think i may miss some coefficient here
some additional
but this one would not work it's just
like
even if there's no shooting if there's
no interaction
if you make that optional to zero
then
you don't have a couple system because
that is reduced to the standard uh
optimal transport problem for optimal
transport is a safe problem we know we
we don't have it a couple of pde like
this
but uh we do also know on the other hand
we know what we get i mean there are
various forms of uh in which we
interpret the optimal transport rate so
yeah i'm just wondering if you look at
what would be the formulation if epsilon
is zero right i understand that this is
not this yes
so if absolute is zero uh
i think normally people will go back to
the one without a logarithmic
transformation which goes back to this
one actually
okay so discretization
so
now we would focus on this formulation
uh minimize the care divergence between
p and q p
if the optimization variable is a
is a
path measure is very
complicated so we discretize this so we
discretize over space and time okay
it's a very traditional method okay then
after you discretize this then the p
becomes a
tensor
m
okay and it's very high dimensional t
plus one dimensional is a huge high
dimensional tensor but it's fine let's
not worry about it for now but if we do
this
the objective function becomes this
okay
so
uh if i
if i just say okay there's no way to
cover
okay if i remove this m here
now this is the entropy regularized
optimal transport problem so everybody
here will know this
so
and this is just entropy i don't need to
define this so the only difference
between this
and that one is really this uh
the cost function the transportation
cost depends on your transportation plan
this creates a non-linearity in your
problem so this is our final formulation
after this transition we call this
non-linear multi-marginal optimal
transport problem
so i just put the constraint back
because this is
what we need to do
okay
so
here the cm looks like this
which is the transportation cost as you
can see the reason this transportation
cost depends on ammo is because
here this term over here we need to use
the margin of m to calculate this term
and this
really
gives you the dependence and if w is
zero then you remove this this really
reduce the quadratic cost
so
okay
so we'll come back to this later so
right now we just focus on this problem
it's just a mot non-linear mot problem
so how do we solve this
how do we solve this it's it's already a
entropy
the
mot it's really really tempting to use a
single right
so but it's not quite there
because this non-linear dependence we
cannot just
apply since directly
so is that other way to read it to
utilize this uh very simple sim card
algorithm
so it turns out we can
so
what we need to do is we need to
utilize another framework called the
proximal gradient algorithm
so in just a detail is that this page is
really
a
completely different notation and
different problem
so proximal gradient algorithm okay it's
a very standard algorithm
to solve composite optimization so in
this problem
we want to minimize this
and we have some constraint set and we
want to minimize this
and normally here in this type of
problem one of the f is
is relatively smooth
and another one g
is may not be smooth
but
normally is
very simple so normally this is a
regularizer okay
so it turns out for this type of problem
this is a very effective algorithm
called the proximal gradient so
basically what you do is you run
gradient descent for this component then
once you have this you run the proximal
map for that part then this looks this
is the total algorithm
okay this is the gradient direction and
proximal map
okay
there is a non-euclidean
extension of this
so so here we have euclidean distance
but there is a non-euclidean one you
just replace this by
a
fragment
divergence
like a k divergence then this is the
null non-euclidean proximal gradient so
this is the plague divergence
okay this algorithm works very very well
even when the problem is non-convex it
has the guarantee to converge to local
solution
and
this is and has sub-linear convergence
and this is really what we need because
our problem actually is it's not in in
general is not the convex
so local solution is
the best you can expect
okay so now we just plug this into our
problem
so this part this algorithm is for
composite optimization so that's just a
lot of problems into a composite
optimization
so we have two parts but this is the
this is the cost part which looks like
this
and this is the entropy part
and i put the constraint i denote the
constraint to be this just means m is
consistent with my marginals
okay
so
for this one if we just run the now you
non-euclidean
now you can read the proximal gradient
then we plug in then this is what we
would get
okay it looks long but it's
quite simple
we take gradient of f
at this iteration
then you have inner product okay there
this is the other part and we have the
scale divergence which is the which is
the proximal path okay
and the clear divergence we know if you
expand this it looks like some linear
plus an entropy part and you just expand
this it looks like this
okay so this is nice why is this nice
this is nice because
because this is a linear function of m
and this is a entropy
and this is in fact what is the mot
problem with this guy being the new cast
and this is the entropy localization
okay
and what even better is
normally when you say mlts the single
algorithm is not stable because the
localization time is very small option
is very small
here
uh the legalization is not even i mean
even if epsilon is zero i can make this
non zero by choosing a relatively small
step size theta i can make this
relatively large really mitigate the
numerical issues of this single
algorithm
so this is our problem and
this is the gradient of f and i'm not
going to discuss more by just a tedious
calculation you can just get the
gradient of f it looks like the cost
plus another term and the other term can
be decomposed in this way okay
just some calculation
okay
so
it's good it's all good but
still
in this algorithm what we need to do is
we need to solve a
sequence of mathematical optimal
transport problem
but as we know
in general
mot problem even a single mot problem
numerically is challenging
you just think about this in this mot
problem
what's the dimension of m
m is a tensor is a t plus one
dimensional tensor and even if you want
to put a computer to save this is
is very it's impossible
so
very often it's very especially for the
application we are interested in
so we need to explore structures
so this leads us to another line of
research we have been working on which
is called the graphical optimal
transport
two minutes okay
okay so let me just say keep moving
so this is mot okay so very often in mot
problem
because the tensor is not just a
is not just a big tensor it has a
structure and very often it has a
graphical structure which meaning
cx can be written as the summation of
many smaller tensors and this is what
happened
in many problems versus very center
spline and also for our problem we have
the structure this is largely due to the
fact that
cm looks like this and this is a
summation of several different terms and
each of this only involves two marginals
so this is the graph corresponding to
that
and
with this graphical structures
we can actually utilize these graphic
structures to significantly accelerate
the computation so this is the
this is the sinkhole algorithm okay this
is not a single this is the
this is the characterization of the
solution
and this is the single algorithm which
is the which is the which looks like
this and it has all the nice properties
except for one that
in every iterations you need to do this
pj k
multiplier u
this is basically you have a huge high
dimensional tensor you want to do the
calculate one of the marginals
if you do this with brute force you need
this amount of calculation which is uh
impossible
so what's good about the graphical
structure is that
you can do this in a much easier way
because this is equivalent to a
variation inference problem in the
probabilistic graphic model community
so i'm going to skip this
and
this is just to show you this operation
what we need is equal to variation
inference
okay
and
by combining this uh advanced algorithm
rather than standard algorithm invasion
influence with the sinkhole
we can get something called the sinkhole
brief propagation really to solve this
mot problem with graphical structure
very fast
okay and finally
this is the the total algorithm we call
this the proximal single complete
variation algorithm is really combined
this algorithm for mot and then combine
this with the proximal gradient
then we sequentially solve this type of
mlt problem
and we get a solution under the want to
emphasize the capacity of each iteration
is nx square multiplied by t
so which is reasonable in most
applications
okay i would skip the extensions you can
if you're interested in that you can
just take a look at the paper
and this is one example it's a
one-dimensional example so it's a
it's a
simple
so just to show you the picture so
this is the
initial configuration
that is the target configuration this is
the time our goal is to control this
from this distribution to this
configuration
i forgot
this is the interaction we
use is a repulsive okay
so if
if beta is zero which means there's no
such interaction then this is the
solution which is the mot solution or
has a sharing a bridge solution because
we have a small noise there
but if we choose other parameters this
is just a few examples
you see
this repulsive force really actually
affects
the evolution of the density and in a
reasonable expected way
and just
one more thing is that
a few possible future directions uh we
are interested in is that granada
algorithm is a is a
is a discretization based
so
it's nice but it's not scalable to have
dimensional problem
we are looking to to see whether a
particle-based
method is possible after seeing this
week's talk i think it's quite promising
it's possible or you can use a learning
method to
use another line of research to to
realize this algorithm or another
thing
i'm thinking of is whether this type of
problem has any connections to the
consensus based sampling
okay
so i think i'm over time
okay thanks yeah
thank you
any questions
thanks
thanks for the talk very nice uh
so i have
um
so a question if you want is on the
on the very beginning if you want so
where you say that uh
you don't want a
particle to cross right
so not to go too close to each other but
so in
this i i get this in general but
for the problem where
basically you are
you want just
going mu to new yes with the control yes
actually so if if the noise is zero
they believe the trajectories that you
get
you know with buses thing two they don't
cross right yes exactly and that's a
very good point and you have this very
good property if you do geodesic
interpolation using optimal transport
but the problem is
in real robot they are not points
so my question my question was
really so
the relation between because again in
the uh
you know in the optimal transport that
uh you have this uh you know convexity
of the infinity norm
of the geodesic
which is basically saying that
you know since it is related in some
sense the inverse of the radii
so
you should expect that radii are not
increasing now of course this this
should be like a hard ball condition
which is not easy to prove and we are
talking about you know five numbers but
yeah would you expect that actually this
is uh
so
this is
really needed
uh i believe this is really needed for
instance
in almost other
in almost other swamp platform i know
there's a really the lowest level
control they always enforce
collision avoidance is automatically
there
i mean the solution property of ultimate
transport map is nice
but i wouldn't really trust that if i
apply this to real robot robotics and
due to their many problems for instance
some disturbance would really destroy
that
so
and but if you have this uh
interaction there then this really you
can guarantee this
reasonably well
thank you very much for the very nice
talk thanks uh i have two questions
actually
can you say if there is anything no like
after you discretize that you get to the
static multi-margin optimal transport
problem yes if he's anything is no on
the limit when epsilon goes to zero
nothing is not because uh we are the
only work in which he discretized this
so in that inverse direction no i didn't
investigate this
yeah but i think it's interesting
problem
yeah i think it should be doable you
just say we we didn't do that yeah
in the second question like could you
comment like if there is any relation
between like the graphic optimal
transport and sinkhorn uh
i believe propagation yes algorithm with
like the works of like maxwelling and
pay yeah
graphical mode
propagation yes that's a very good point
it turns out
these two algorithms coincide
significantly
and we after we developed this framework
actually we found out this algorithm and
this method
so but the angle we look at this problem
is completely different
yes so there the way they look at this
they just
it's like a relaxation so initially you
have a
dilated measurement like they just relax
this by some distributions
so here
we started so basically they started
from the graphic model point of view we
studied the flow
and there and we started from the mot
point of view and we end up with the
same algorithm
thanks yeah that's a that's a paper
there
it's the same algorithm okay one last
question and then we can take it offline
you say something about how robust
can you say
can you say anything about the stability
of the optimal control to perturbations
of the of the measures
um anything quantitative or something
that's a very good question
[Music]
the answer is i i don't know we didn't
investigate this and actually what i
presented to you here is you see after
this transition there is our step
missing is that
after you get this m for instance you
need to do some approximation to recover
because the policy has to be a
continuous map like you need some other
approximation over there to recover some
uh
candidate of the optimal control so even
there there's no errors
so
yeah we didn't investigate the stability
over there yeah we just
we just carried out some algorithm and
uh
and the one advantage of this algorithm
is that
you see we have to solve a sequential as
several iterations of mot
but the good thing is that you don't
have to really
go to the very end because
you just stop anywhere
due to this
specific structure if you stop anywhere
this of the leads to a feasible control
which would do the job and i mean this
may not minimize the cost but this would
drive really the initial to the target
so it's always feasible along the whole
path which is a nice property of this
algorithm
thanks
okay thank you very much for a beautiful
talk
[Applause]
and this brings us to the end of a
wonderful workshop and let's uh upload
for simone and cathy
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much from all
of us
and let's applaud for all the speakers
[Applause]
yes very very
very beautiful
and and yes and absolutely
simon's institute and the great great
support that we got
[Applause]
thank you
thank
you okay well i'll make a few
final remarks i